i love this this story about what humans
used to think the brain was made of
based on the current science of the time
like steam pressure
now we believe brains are more like
computers because we've invented
computers
maybe we're getting closer maybe we're
not maybe eventually we'll think it's
magnetic plasma or something
but what we're seeing the rise of a
religion
because they were raised without that
religion they were raised without that
moral framework
and they're actively being converted i
look at you know i think maybe a really
good way to explain it is
is a a prion disease or a prime how we
pronounce it are you familiar with what
that is
yeah prion disease so basically we have
a structure
of self-replicating proteins that is our
system
and woke are malformed proteins that
when they come into contact with healthy
proteins
malformed them these proteins can't work
in the body and eventually lead to the
body's
death and destruction so uh i think what
was it med cow disease was that
their brain disease eventually your
brain stops working and then you die
because the proteins aren't connecting
anymore properly so malfunction
let's get to that what is malfunctioning
because i i mean that's something in
terms of
getting back to hegel and just is there
objective truth or not
and for people to be making objective
truth statements
that it's contradictory for you to say
there there's no such thing as
as absolutes but that in and of itself
is an absolute statement
right so i think that again we find
ourselves
you know i like the movie as a surfer
180 degrees south where the
patagonia founders that are into surfing
and climbing and all that they
at one point in the movie say that you
know you want to be progressive
well at some point if you're going the
wrong way it's progressive to turn
around and go 180 degrees the other
direction
and i think in terms of our ability as a
civilization i like how oz guinness
calls we're living in a cut flower
society
where we're enjoying so much of the
fruits of western civilization and a lot
of ideas that come from athens that come
from greece people for thousands of
years have been
developing ways to reason you know
empiricism the scientific method
so we see a lot of yard signs in seattle
that say science is real
okay what is science and what is real
science how do we actually do that and
in our case you know in terms of
applying uh
to all these issues just trying to think
clearly and think well
um about in our case how do you do
mental health work but
even these bigger questions of what's
true
if um i like to heard one you were
talking about how there was something
about where like um
i don't know if there's a proton or
electron like that's that was orbiting a
vacuum
yeah yeah so it was uh uh it was a
trapped
in uh in a circuit with no nucleus and
it exhibited the chemical properties of
what it normally would with a single
electron in orbit
and when they injected more electrons
into it it exhibited the chemical
properties
of the appropriate atom with no nucleus
yeah so that's i mean that's
it seems like that's kind of what's
going on right now is that as grace was
saying earlier that you know you can't
just remove this particular project
without being clear on what you're going
to put in its place and i would just
hope that we can just
take a deep breath and look at some of
the skills that our brothers and sisters
have developed over a long period of
time in terms of
just doing dialogue better um doing
science better because that's something
we've seen the american psychological
association association and others are
out of their lane they're dealing with
things that are philosophical
ontological that are not
empirical and that are that's that's
messing things up and we just need some
some honesty and some
some carefulness around the way that we
approach things and i'd love to
you know continue conversations around
things like
you know what what really is at the root
of these questions of what is true
but i think that you know fundamentally
we all share the values of wanting to
love people
and in our case we've just seen in a
particular way in which
loving people depends on truth right
and and that matters you know yeah i you
know a lot of what we see with the woke
is comforting lies
yeah they'll they'll tell you something
they'll make you feel good but will
destroy everything
and maybe it maybe it's a it's a lack of
uh
i guess foresight a lack of perspective
or vision or understanding
it's it's uh i'll give you a really
simple and uh
physical example real world example
someone posted on facebook earlier about
uh you know gun control
no one's gonna take away your guns blah
blah blah and i was like here's a list
of the guns of mine that are already
being banned like they're already banned
in most places
and then they just come out with memes
like their knowledge is based on memes
they think they're helping
but they're angry there's no
conversation i can tell you outright
m1a banned maryland why well they
already took my gun away
you got you can't have it here in
maryland there are people who genuinely
believe
false things and because of that want to
build in the wrong direction which would
ultimately cause pain and suffering to a
lot of people
but when you're arrogant and you just
i guess egotistical maybe a lack of true
philosophical understanding
you're willing to burn down the entire
system for the sake of claiming you're
right it's
it's a problem humans have i suppose i
think a lot of critical theorists
disagree with the scientific method have
issues with it and
something about that that's interesting
they call it the scientific method but
it's just
one aspect of science it's you could
call it the floorbow method you could
call it like dark method or whatever
it's it's a method of measuring
something
over and over and over again to make
sure that it continues to happen
and then you can say okay fine that is
real and if you if if it doesn't happen
over and over again then you say it's
not
real but a problem with reality is
sometimes things happen and they don't
happen over and over again because
they're happening for reasons we don't
understand or can't measure
and so the scientific method is flawed
and it's it's saying
people are taking issue with that they
just don't have another type of science
yet to explain why someone might be born
with male genitalia but feel like
the gender is female but it's flawed in
the sense that we're imperfect but
the fact that you recognize its flawed
in science recognize its limitations
means
it serves its purpose humility yeah it's
epistemic humility it's not arrogance
it's not you may not challenge
it's like please keep challenging it's
quite simple it's um
uh what's what's the saying those who
are uh
who are smart are so full of doubt you
know the ignorant are so sure of
themselves something that if
something like that who wrote that was
it i don't know
but uh that's the issue is that i can
simply say
when it comes to issues of universal
health care versus private health care
well i don't i don't know i don't have
the answers i'd love to look over the
data and figure out a plan to move
forward
but then you end up with zealots who say
the answer is clearly
one done if you don't want it you're bad
and i will fight you so that was
bertrand russell he said the whole
problem with the world is that
fools and fanatics are always so certain
of themselves and whys are people so
full of doubts
100 percent like the wiser you get the
more you're like oh i'm probably not
right
call me on this yeah the people uh i
look at this way
you've got uh five doors in front of you
four of them lead to sweet sweet freedom
one of them leads to a lion cage well
i feel the door give a little knock
then i'm finally on door number four i
hear oh my okay that that's not that or
i'm sorry it should be
four of them lead to lions cages one to
freedom and so i just like bang bang
bang
and then i hear the roar bang my bang
hero finally i bang on one i hear
nothing
i look down look under the crack of the
door i see some light and i'm like i
think that one's door to freedom
i don't know for sure but let's take a
peek i open it i see sunlight i say all
right it's my best guess
makes sense i gathered evidence and i
moved quickly and then i bring the
people behind me with me to freedom
but too many people are like i don't
care number one
you know my politician said door number
one is the right door and they open and
their line jumps out then they claim
it's your fault
it's it's see the system is broken
there's lions in this room well
you you let the lion in so
i think what we're getting to though is
so rationalism
has clearly failed you know like we
can't we can't just with our brains in
which our with our senses completely
comprehend
reality and then i think empiricism also
has its limits right because empiricism
can only
still observe what exists in the natural
realm
and then we have all this other
knowledge that is true that is a part of
us like the transcendent like
why do we love what is beautiful why do
we want what is good
why do we seek the truth and all like
science doesn't
talk about that so these are like the
ultimate things that everyone is
answering and everyone has arrived at
even if it's just sort of an agnostic i
don't know no one knows like that is
still the framework
out of which you're operating and so
what i see happening also with this
critical social justice movement is that
they've actually arrived at a
transcendent version of science they're
saying
that the you know the classic you know
textbook definition of science
didn't isn't good because there's all
these other knowledges and they use that
where knowledge is plural
that we need to be observing we need we
need to be carefully
you know listening to because those
views have been pushed out to the margin
and in a way i'm like i think you're
right
and it's not it's not that people's
individual kind of standpoint
epistemology is
is going to get us to all the answers
you know that that's that's a fallacious
way of thinking
but there is the sense in which we need
something that also transcends the
empirical like
rationalism enough is not enough
empiricism is not enough
there's more knowledge that is so true
to reality and to our understanding of
our self in reality that science doesn't
touch
this is why i say i don't think that the
the left the woke
are acting in any sense of good faith
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you